I was lucky enough to be born into a
situation where the basic necessities of
life food shelter clothing education
were freely available to me nothing I
did I just happened it and get it and
then there's billion people on the
planet nothing needed don't get it there
is absolutely no reason why these
essential basics of life aren't
available to everyone on the planet
[Music]
there is a responsibility by those who
have the privilege to amplify the voices
of those who might not
poverty is a man-made problem and we can
solve it always keep our true north
focused on a world without extreme
poverty by 2030 if you have the money to
pay for bill then you get out that's
just not fair if we can get just one
little girl into school every day you've
changed the world we have to look at the
things that we take for granted like
waste
it's our ambition to make all
head-and-shoulders packaging 100%
recyclable by 2030
our president is going to make an
announcement and it's gonna be huge
[Applause]
there is 50% less extreme poverty than I
was 20 years ago it's very important for
me to see a change like this happen it's
our responsibility to make sure everyone
knows
[Applause]